on parle de livres et j'ai bien sûr
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
après cette intervention du pape cette
semaine alors vous allez tous réagir
dessus est ce que vous êtes pour est ce
que vous êtes contre le débat sur le
plateau est un petit peu déséquilibré
puisqu'il n'y a qu'une personne qui
contre lee berger c'est emile du port
fondateur et porte parole du mouvement
les survivants vous réagissez chez vous
voilà sur twitter sur tous les réseaux
sociaux hashtag balances ton poste et
après juste après on parlera de la
sexualité en 2018 les français plus
libre que jamais et vous allez voir que
sur le plateau et sur ce plateau il va y
avoir de la liberté merci emile d'être
avec nous et 1000 donc vous représentez
des survivants je les dis c'est un
groupement john né après 1975 qui ont
survécu à la loi sur libé g pourquoi
êtes vous contre lille et j'ai dit nous
puisque ici tout le monde est pour
et je pense que beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs sont courts également
donc qu'est ce que vous pourriez dire
pour les faire changer d'avis écoutez
pour moi le meilleur ivg c'est celui
qu'on est vite et je pense que liv et
j'ai en france l'avortement nous fait
beaucoup de mal
parce qu'en fait il prive un enfant sur
cinq de la chance de naître premièrement
dans un pays qui est riche et prospère
comme le nôtre est ce que on ne peut pas
se poser la question de dire et surtout
qu'à la prétention se prête de se dire
le pays des droits de l'homme et qui est
pas foutu de respecter la première
égalité qui est la plus fondamentale qui
est l'égalité dans la naissance
ben voilà on vient poser une question
est ce qu'on est ce qu'on peut pas faire
quelque chose pour réduire le nombre des
ivg je rappelle qu'il ya quand même deux
cent vingt mille avortements pour 800
mille naissances c'est un enfant sur
cinq est que ça concerne une femme sur
deux l'enfant existe si l'enfant existe
il est semble suffisamment prouvé tout
le depuis longtemps existé moi j'ai été
sept embryons et ma mère n'avait aucun
droit sur moi
et qu'est ce que vous dites en fait aux
femmes qui ont été violées et qui ont
qui sont par la suite tombée enceinte à
ben alors mois déjà il ne m'appartient
pas de leur dire ou de noël quoi que ce
soit vis alors mon avis sur le viol
alors c'est très compliqué alors déjà
sur les 220 me d'avortement n'y a pas
deux cent vingt mille femmes violées et
isolés de leur famille sur souvent la
responsabilité de l'avortement il est
lié à la pression de l'entourage
mais pour les femmes violées et je vais
répondre à la question je pense que
c'est une vraie violence
le viol est une violence atroce
l'avortement est aussi une violence et
je pense qu'il faut quand simone veil
parler de détresse je pense qu'elle
elle évoquait sa la détresse du viol
mais simplement n'a pas spécifié donc en
fait pour moi toute forme de grossesse à
un moment donné est une détresse parce
qu'en fait il n'est jamais facile de
devenir la demeure d'un autre pour une
femme
et si elle n'est pas soutenue elle aura
des moments de détresse donc en fait en
stipulant pas sur le viol eh ben on a
étendu finalement à tous les cas
possibles et imaginables
maintenant moi je pose une question aux
femmes qui ont été violées c'est et à la
société c'est est ce que il est
finalement bon de faire un cumul des
peines
c'est à dire de 10 de sucres de cumuler
une violence du viol à la violence de
deûle ivg se pose une question d'avoir
une femme quand même nom mais je
comprends qu'ils veuillent pas que
l'enfant de son violeur lui conte dans
les pattes effectué assez clair années a
clamé par contre on peut quand même se
dire est ce qui est ce que on est est ce
que il ya une forme d'héroïsme à
répondre à la haine par l'amour alors
oui mais kana nous proposer à mes
devoirs et de la question moi j'ai rien
à proposer dans ces cas là oui mais
émile emile moi j'aimerais j'aimerais
qu'on entende
l'avis de fatima fatima benomar
féministe porte-parole des effrontées
est ce que ça vous choque
quand vous entendez la réaction est ce
que dit amy du port évidemment que ça me
choque parce que ne serait ce que parce
que son mouvement s'appelle les
survivants il faut pas oublier que on
est minorité de privilégiés dans ce
monde à vivre dans un pays où le droit à
l'avortement existe en est que 39 % de
femmes et dans la majeure partie des cas
dans ce monde et dans l'histoire les
femmes n'ont pas le choix du nombre
d'enfants qu'elles auront de la
temporalité pour les avoir et ça fait
dans les pays prohibitionniste sait même
pas qu'il ya eu une baisse de l'accès à
l'avortement c'est que moi par exemple
je suis marocaine je viens d'un pays qui
produit qui a une position symbolique de
prohibition de l'avortement les femmes
qui sont riches qu'ils ont eu des
opportunités on les contacte dans les
cliniques pour pouvoir avoir les femmes
les autres ce sont les avortements
clandestins quand une femme décide
d'avorter le fait dans n'importe quelles
conditions
c'est quoi des avortements clandestins
ce sont des produits chimiques ce sont
des aiguilles entre les cuisses ce sont
des coups de pied dans le ventre c'est
tout un marché de charlatans il ya deux
options existent il ya 20 ans dans le
monde parents d'avortements clandestins
et pour quelqu'un qui porte par les
survivants il ya 47 mille femmes dans le
monde qui meurent des suites d'un
avortement clandestin
et je ne parle même pas des femmes
emprisonnées il ya encore eu le cas de
belene qui est une femme en argentine
qui a été emprisonné pour ça il ya
toujours des avoirs talent clandestins
quand même mois on revient là jo journée
en france pourquoi on revient là dessus
aujourd'hui on va rappeler les propos du
pape françois qui a comparé donc
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
pour au cours un tueur à gages
il a dit ce n'est pas juste de se
débarrasser d'un être humain même petit
pour résoudre un problème c'est comme
avoir recours un tueur à gages pour
résoudre un problème et si salon qui a
relancé le débat cette semaine
vous vous êtes d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire lui savonner la planche
parce que c'est sûr que c'est une c'est
une phrase qui est vraiment violente
or l'avortement cesser la violence par
essence et donc du coup je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de victimes dans
l'avortement que deux coupables et donc
du coup le fait de faire passer les
femmes pour des commanditaires de tueurs
à gages
alors que souvent elles sont obligées
d'avorter bah c'est sûr c'est pas très
malin
agathe au prix donc l'église est contre
l'avortement l'a toujours été il ya
toujours eu ce genre de déclarations un
peu
un peu ridicule ça ça ne change pas mais
que les s'est vu tout le monde excusez
ma déclaration ridicule je partage la
position que je respecte même si je ne
la partage pas le droit à l'avortement
et la loi veil c'est l'une des avancées
les plus symboliques dans le droit de la
femme dans le droit de toutes les femmes
aient le droit de la femme à disposer de
son corps c'est absolument
je ne comprends pas comment vous pouvez
nier à une mère qui n'en est pas qui n'a
pas envie de l'être et qui ne peut pas
assumer cet enfant pour les raisons qui
lui hand qui lui incombent elle n'a même
pas sans justifier de de vouloir
interrompre sa grossesse dans les délais
imposés par la loi parce que c'est pas
désarçonné avel dro ne s'est pas désuni
euro va céder avant te ment règlement
les personne n'avait le droit de
disposer de mon corps et ton corps
n'existait pas mais bien sûr que s'il
était bel et bien sûr qu'il existait
milk alors un embryon n'est pas un être
humain c'est sur dix est en train de
soutenir c'est le nom brille on est un
être humain science il fait fi des
règles c'est le base c'est la base de la
science médicale qui le dit simplement
aux frères m'ont dit c'est pas une
personne humaine
voyez la schizophrénie du truc c'est à
dire on dit c'est un être humain mais
par contre c'est une personne si on le
désire donc finalement le désir d'autrui
devient la variable d'ajustement de la
dignité d'autrui
alors laquelle ce site on en train de
construire les désirs il ya des femmes
qui ont eu et qui avait une grossesse
qui n'était pas attendu et puis
finalement c'était une bonne nouvelle en
garde et on a dit c'est un objet de
désir il ya des femmes qui vont galérer
un endroit on n'est pas un désir n'est
pas un objet un enfant est en net ce
n'est pas un objet a été tranché par la
loi mais il ya un autre aspect c'est que
cette scène apparemment cette histoire
dit vg est utilisé par toutes sortes de
réactionnaire pour une reprise en main
de ceux de la société et notamment des
femmes et du corps des femmes en général
sous l'égide des églises s'est pas
seulement les catholiques c'est pareil
pour l'islam en général c'est toujours
l'église qui est en pointe et d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas un hasard si ces propos de
quand même très choquant viennent du
passé aussi contre ça qu'on se bat alors
laissé un retour en arrière avec
l'église qui nous explique ce qu'il faut
faire ce qu'il faut pas alors justement
de les décrire du tout il ya le prêtre
laurent scala bourdillon qui a défendu
le pape au micro d'europe 1 regardez
faut porter et une réflexion sur
là la conscience de ce que représente la
suppression d'une vie parce que plein
pour la doctrine catholique
nous avons tous été un embryon donc puis
un an
ces petits étaient sur le chemin de la
vie et on les arrête pour 36 raison
alors en fait la question c'est que
c'est les questions de confort mais
demain ça va être aussi l'élimination de
d'enfants à naître grave est qu une
pathologie déclaré ou même sans
pathologie déclaré donc en fait c'est
une sorte de 2,2 d'alert que le pape
peut lancer comme ça dans sa catéchèse
du matin alors c'est vrai qu'il a eu des
mots très durs le pas bon bien sûr lui
des obligés de le défendre
eric revel alors d'abord je sais pas ce
qu'il lui a pris ou papillon c'est un
pape progrès 6 jusqu'à il ya quelques
mois et tout d'un coup il devient ultra
conservateur et avec des sorties qui
sont absolument hallucinante
moi je peux pas m'opposer à une loi il
ya une loi qui consacre les vg et bah je
résous attendait mais je vais vous dire
une chose
en revanche j'ai relu certains passages
de la loi qui avait porté simone veil
elle écrit il dit
je le dis avec toute ma conviction
l'avortement doit rester l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
la loi sur les vga était quand même très
distordue en 2014 on a supprimé la
notion de détresse c'est à dire qu'une
femme qui avorte n'est pas seulement une
femme en détresse donc on voit bien que
cette loi qui est un vrai progrès pour
les femmes et son ça que j'essaie de
tempérer un peu les propos est devenu
aussi une sorte de substitut parfois un
acte de contraception et c'est ça qui
peut être un sujet au delà du débat
entre l'embryon ou l'enfant c'est à dire
que la loi veil -le stipulé ensemble de
choses qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus où
on était complètement déformée et rendue
publique on va redonner les conditions
pour apporter pas de condition d'âge à
respecter pas nécessaire d'avoir
l'accord des parents et être avant la
douzième semaine de grossesse alors
c'était il ya quarante quatre ans que la
regrettée simone veil alors ministre de
la santé change à l'histoire avec ces
mots prononcés à l'assemblée nationale
devant 95 % d'hommes c'était le 26
novembre 1974
regardez je le dis avec toute ma
conviction l'avortement doit rester
l'exception
l'ultime recours pour des situations
sans issue nous pensons ainsi répondre
au désir conscient ou inconscient de
toutes les femmes qui se trouvent dans
cette situation d'un envoi actuellement
celles qui se trouvent dans cette
situation de détresse qui s'en préoccupe
combien sont ils ceux qui se sont
préoccupés d'aider ces femmes dans leur
détresse
combien sont ils ceux qui au delà de ce
qu'ils jugent comme une faute ont su
manifester aux jeunes mères célibataires
la compréhension et l'appui moral dont
elle avait un si grand besoin
voilà alors on voulait on voulait revoir
ces images c'est vrai que c'est nous
allons voir ça a vraiment viré nous
avons ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les chiffres n'ont pas bougé les
chiffres des reventes mans n'ont pas
bougé vous pouvez confirmer depuis 75 à
ce moment là jusqu'à aujourd'hui on est
toujours à 200 220 milles 1 il est donné
très important c'est juste oui toi tu
vois je puis me permettre c'est que à
l'époque c'était une loi a minima comme
vous l'avez rappelé simone veil est en
train de s'exprimer devant près de 500
hommes et les femmes dans un contexte
extrêmement dur parce qu'elle était
portée par les luttes des mouvements
féministes
donc effectivement c'était en droit à
l'avortement restera qui n'était pas
démocratisé c'est pour cela par exemple
le remboursement à 100% c'est important
sinon ça devient droit de riches donc
toutes les avancées que eu pour le droit
à l'avortement ces dernières années sont
des avancées réelles mais bref à dire à
simone veil de ce qu'ils aiment bien
c'est confirmé ni infirmé mois pour moi
c'est la lutte de 6 est bien de rappeler
les propos qu'elle tenait des propos
qu'elle tenait j'ai vu à face que
youtube est politique il était obligé
d'avoir presque un discours charitable
ces femmes sont dans la détresse de
toute manière il ya trois cent mille
femmes qui avortent de manière
clandestine
mais depuis on n'est plus dans cette
position là on peut revendiquer un droit
à l'avortement il faut rappeler que la
plupart des femmes qui avortent la
grande majorité utiliser la
contraception aujourd'hui dans les
avancées de la science
on a aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune
contraception qui est sûr à 100% donc ce
qui est important c'est à donner aux
femmes les accès à une vraie éducation
sexuelle à une vraie information à tous
les moyens de contraception parce que
plus fans et laverty pelé consciente que
la des comportements mature et plus on
stigmatise le droit à l'avortement et à
la contraception plus ils ont des
conduites à risque parce que elles
vivent dans un environnement de thabo
elles n'ont pas accès à toutes les
toutes les bonnes informations
liv et gide est toujours menacée on voit
il ya plein voilà il ya plein d'action
vous avez même fait une action sur le
plateau de tpm paix avec vos équipes je
crois que c'était l'an dernier et sur le
jt de france 2 ils ont montré une
histoire incroyable aux états unis
certains hôpitaux n'hésite pas à montrer
des reportages de reconstitution
totalement fausse pour dissuader des
patientes d'avorter regardez c'est ouf
ça le film décrit un avortement à en
semaine scientifiquement rien d' inexact
mais les mots sont choisis pour effrayer
le bébé rapidement déchiquetés par la
force de l'aspiration et écraser pour
être évacués dans le tua prochain la
vidéo montre un petit corps et on voit
comment retire une jambe puis l'autre
puis le bras cette vidéo m'a montré que
j'avais une vie en moins et j'ai dit non
je ne veux pas avorter alors vous avez
fait plein d'action aussi on doit tous
allongés
la ministre de l'égalité hommes-femmes
qui aimons voir sms qui apparemment elle
nous regarde
elle me dit entraver l'accès des femmes
à libé g est un délit dans la loi
française et les femmes qui avortent ne
sont pas des ados mais statistiquement
des femmes de 30 40 ans de marley no
scaffa avant de faire pour cent des
idées des femmes avortent avant 24 ans
alors je dis avec un ami qu'elle regarde
ces chiffres celle d'origine
elle a les bons chiffres mais non mais
non 44 % des femmes avortent avant 24
ans ça concerne les jeunes femmes à
l'avortement est et ce qui est triste
c'est qu'on considère qu'une femme à 16
ans est mûr pour avoir des rapports
sexuels mais on est potes on considère
pas qu'elle est mûr pour pour être maman
or les deux sont liés et si elles le
sont chez eux soit elle va au terme de
sa grossesse alors attendez c'est pas
une histoire de choix aux deux pas de
choix et des sensations geste mais les
tendeurs jockey l'énorme impact
interrompre une grossesse c'est ça c'est
vous qui le décrit ce qui est permis
n'est pas profitable
c'est pas parce que vous êtes en train
de me dire c'est permis que ça nous a
rendu heureux époux mais ce qui est
permis mais bien c'est tout entière et
sable et les femmes enceintes et les
femmes heureuses et les femmes qui
voulaient pas d'enfant car elles peuvent
ne pas me mêler les réseaux sociaux
regorgent de message complètement
dramatique de fitch qui appelle à l'aide
et qui peuvent pas exprimer lors que
leur culpabilité tout et qu'ils disent
mais en fait j'ai ma balise est aidée à
avorter à tous mais attendez il ya eu
des milliers de messages vous laisse
hors jeu vous les imprime et c'est pour
ça que je militais c'est à dire il est
pur non vraiment et après l'ont battu
pendant des années au nom alors excusez
moi pour faire de ce qu'ils ont sur la
comète d'un événement à l'ehpad ans de
sannois la vc3 d'en souffrir tirant
alors gamme ces deux pays aux émeutes
qui ont porté la grossesse à terme et
qui toute la vie ont battu leur noël et
je connais beaucoup j'en connais bilan
serait proche de alors parce qu'elle est
femme a livré dans l'autre sens s'il
vous plaît karim zéribi qu'on n'a pas du
tout entendu sur le sujet non moi il ya
un argument de notre invité kim à fatima
benomar dont deux n'avaient pas retenu
le nom fatima pardon qui est assez
convaincant je trouve c'est que la
plupart des femmes qui recourent à
libérer utilisent des moyens de
contraception
ce qui veut dire que ces femmes là ne
souhaite pas avoir d'enfant s'il ivg
étaient utilisés tels moyens
contraception je serai très dubitatif
mais ça n'est pas le cas ça n'est pas le
cas or moi je respecte contrairement à
monsieur qui balaye d'un revers de main
le désir d'enfant moi je dis qu'une
femme qui met un enfant au monde a
minima si cet enfant n'est pas désirée
je ne vois pas quel va être l'amour le
bonheur du val andré et donc je
considère que c'est un progrès en 1975
que cette loi car elle permet aux femmes
d'avoir un enfant si elle le souhaite si
elle le désire et pas simplement se sont
mesurés ou pas viol et saveurs cas
dramatique mais moi je considère
monsieur je ne suis pas une femme vous
n'êtes pas eu non plus que je sache que
mai
nous en connaissons que il ya combien de
femmes n'ont pas eu recours arrivées g
on était presque dans l'obligation
d'avoir un enfant à une époque et la vie
de cet homme femme et leur vie ont
quasiment été brisées vous préférez ça
l'obligation au choix libre au choix 10
au lieu de choix mais la mortalité des
femmes qui comme les libertés les jeunes
veulent pas lâcher autant faire on peut
parler des gens n'avaient jamais femme
et mère par rapport à la contraception
mais le rapport à leur sérieux par
rapport à la contraception mais l'homme
d'un gros problèmes qui leur pose c'est
de devoir négocier le port de la
contraception par rapport à l'homme qui
est souvent essaye de négocier de ne pas
porter un bernard l'apathie des mois
j'ai même avant la liberté et le droit
de la femme c'est elle qui choisit
oui bah et il aurait c'est comme ça que
j'ai même je me demande pourquoi quand
on veut revenir dessus en tournée dès
lors que ça revient perpétuellement oui
je suis c'est vrai que le solo de chine
le père françois nous avait montré non
mais il était vêtu en arrière la vidéo
déclarations malheureuses homosexuels et
sur libé oui ils ont laminé par la syrie
si le pape n'est jamais revenu à nice il
a toujours eu ses positions même avant
d'être parmi les témoins j'ai regardé là
j'ai regardé avant de venir à l'émission
les positions du pape avant qu'il le
devienne il a toujours eu des positions
très conservatrices sur les questions de
la famille le pape en plus quelqu'un de
progressistes quand il faut parler de
pauvreté
quand il faut parler des vraies là il
est très bon et moi ça me semble à peine
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce qu'il
n'a pas froid aux yeux les fermes il ne
bouge ça ne rend pas service avec lui à
faire je vais vous dire il a quand même
un sujet sur lequel il faut qu'ils
s'occupent ben ali peut être aussi
graves les juifs que les tueurs à gages
et lille évoque mais c'est la fédé avec
tout ça paie de finir mais aujourd'hui
il est obligé peut prendre le contôle ça
c'est fait je dire l'amérique latine en
espagne quand il ya des élections contre
le droit à l'avortement donc ce soir des
militants conquis le droit à la vérité
moi je dirais que c'est culturel
ce monsieur est très sympathique mais
malheureusement les gens qui partagent
votre combat le sont beaucoup moins
ce sont des réactionnaires alors qu'ils
sont manipulés par
c'est le retour des vieux rires je r
manipuler mais sinon vous vous êtes pas
manipuler mais mais mais simplement
c'est on veut remettre en place
l'église qui décide qui est bien ce qui
est mal alors c'est toujours mortes et y
compris aux états unis s'est porté par
des mouvements évangélistes par des
mouvements religieux qui veulent revenir
en arrière très sympathique sabbatique
ça un militant de la manif pour tous il
a fait appel voyez vers le ses tarifs et
bendahmane qui faisait de la
désinformation revoyez la chronique non
mais ça pense aux femmes qui avaient
besoin de allah et ben rob goris qu'il
épiait j'ai regardé les réponses et la
désinformation vous confondez avec ce
qui était fait ou autres plateformes
renvoyé à celle d'yves et j'ai peur et
je voudrais juste en juin dernier mot
souvenons de sunu des basques avaient 10
simone de beauvoir cette fois ci elle
avait dit chaque fois que la société
sera déstabilisé qui aura des crises
économiques etc démocratique on essayera
de revenir sur les droits à l'avortement
en france on a l'impression et c'est
très bien que ce plateau soit encore
positif
on ne sait pas ce qui se serait passé si
par exemple un candidat qui se disait
publiquement contre l'avortement par
exemple monsieur fillon quelles
politiques publiques il aurait mené pour
restreindre le droit à l'avortement donc
restons vigilants théo 6 ans
représentait on donne de la force et de
l'énergie aux femmes dans le monde
là il ya récemment la campagne d
argentine qui ont essayé d'arracher le
droit à l'avortement s'est passé
malheureusement très proches l ont perdu
au sénat
il faut continuer à se mobiliser a donné
de l'énergie du courage aux femmes qui
se voyait le droit de juger docteur
événement quand même endroit que curé
qui est très important à prendre en
compte
malgré l'idée j'ai quitte une loi
française de 1905 15 la france reste le
pays en europe où le taux de fécondité
de plus élevé ce qui signifie que les vg
n'empêche pas la france d'être
championne d'europe et c'est ce que
disait que les biens qu'il est je
n'entends pas bougé voilà depuis des
années des amicales gynéco votre avis
là-dessus puisque vous procurer toujours
les débats gyneco bien
j'ai envie de trouver à j'ai trouvé que
vous aviez été parfaite
j'ai envie de trouver un bon point à
notre ami quand même c'est sympa merci
j'ai vu que tu m'explique pourquoi
l'embryon pour toi est vivant et là je
pourrais te rejoindre parce qu'en fait
l'embryon c'est un petit amas de
cellules était un gros amas de cellules
mais il n'y a rien qui te différencie
grâce à ses cheveux
[Rires]